so my boyfriend is receiving a pretty
large settlement um in the next coming
months and we're kind of debating uh
we're we're looking to buy our first
home um and obviously once the home
comes uh once the right home comes will
will do that but he's stuck on paying
the house out in full um and I'm
wondering if it's better to do a big
down payment and get a mortgage on the
house why do you want a mortgage I don't
I don't know I feel like putting a huge
lump of that settlement into a house why
do why do you want a mortgage I I'm not
I'm not sure well you just told me you
wanted a mortgage well let me uh send
him a warning through
you and you're not going to like this
okay okay there is no we you're not
married exactly yeah there's a he coming
I'm coming into it yeah exactly there's
a he it's his money